monsieur mélenchon alors est ce que
c'est parce que ça lui a bonne religion
qu'il faut les messieurs mélenchon et
eric zemmour répond d'ali ziri j'aurais
pu vous me fait de la peine moi le cher
oui vous me fait de la peine parce que
j'ai connu à monsieur mélenchon qui
était un républicain et qui n'avait pas
peur d'affronter les religions quand
elle empiète et c'est ce que je fais
quand je sais moi finir voyez vous ne me
laissez pas finir web un jeu de bonne
foi ça vous embête ce que je vais dire
parce que vous savez ce que je vais dire
vous étiez car vous étiez en moulin
comme vous alors là moi wahou s'cusez
moi je suis pas un politicien depuis 50
ans donc le moulin est un commentateur
qui me prend car yves dubus comment je
voyais et contrairement à vous parce que
vous vous avez toujours un poste au
chaud
[Musique]
vous plaindre non je ne demande pas de
plein fouet baril vaut mieux pas ça
alors ça pourrait mais ce que vous
pourriez me laisser parler allez on
répond à la question donc monsieur
mélenchon mais je voudrais pas vous
dîtes république a et vous commencez par
ironisé sur quelqu'un qui est élu j'ai
été nommé mais je fais tes choix mais
c'est papa trompe comme c'est moi là
dessus que jérôme
et moi tu vas payer par contre public
depuis 50 ans les impôts des français
depuis cinquante ans bobo et alors et
bah alors au marché c'est tout alors de
manga talon alors embaucher entre les
herbes rouges et ludivine et vous qui me
rend triste
c'est ça
notre mentalité moi je viens d'en bas
d'accord et ben moi aussi oui bah alors
moi aussi voilà pourquoi vous râlez je
ne râle pas pour ça et vous le savez
très bien alors pourquoi vous donnera
d'ailleurs d'abord parce que vous ne me
laissez les parler bien tant pis si
mélenchon
sa rivale et comme dit elle vraiment un
impôt fachos qui l'a dirigé
dépendre de parler expliquer aux enfants
ce sale et à l'école ces publics vous
avez pas bénéficié des apories centre
formé mais oui quel rapport y joue le
dit mais c'est vraiment là pour actions
et des passions malina ciom élan restons
sur le débat entre les élus en parle et
que je me remette
alors dites leur que c'est bon comme ça
on va voir j'aimerais bien pouvoir le
dire les six mois pour quand j'ai connu
monsieur mélenchon c'était un
républicain qui comme album qui combat
telle influence des religions dans la
république
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il se soumet à la
religion musulmane quand j'ai connu
avait l'intention de se mêler chose il
disait que il qu il ne connaissait pas
le mot islamophobie car on avait le
droit de critiquer les religions et
aujourd'hui évidemment vous cherchez un
électorat de substitution monsieur
mélenchon s'est compris nous pour vous
parce que vous et la gauche vous avez
perdu le peuple français alors
évidemment vous cherchez un électorat de
substitution et vous avez trouvé les
musulmans dont vous êtes prêts à toutes
les bassesses regardez ce que toutes les
ignominies garder il vous êtes prêts à
tout les apostasies
vous savez quand je dire le moins
possible pour ça que justement
les lumières et c'est à dire non non le
combat où la mairie à 9 à des laïcs
contre l'église catholique mais contre
l'islam là il ya plus personne vous
recoucher monsieur m dans le monde
entier ça y est ah les ongles incarnés
hollywood john
harbour comment je vous ai déjà dit
respecter votre contradicteur il ya
aucun vaunage ne suis plus un milieu du
ve n'y a qu'un bonhomme vous devriez
avoir honte de ce que vous est ce qu'il
marque lorsque mon esprit vous ferez le
mélange vous cherchez un électorat de
subventionnement et vous dites les
musulmans parce que les musulmans ils
sont pas français ils sont français
quand il se trompe
merci
monsieur ces vies n'étaient pas protégés
d'un deal entre elles dit une cliente
oui oui enfin vous avez vous cherchez
vous prêt à tout renier
sac et réécouter vous n'êtes pas capable
de supporter la suite parce que vous
venez déjà de renier vos compatriotes
musulmans jeu monsieur les deux tiers de
ceux qui sont morts à monte cassino
étaient des musulmans alors quand les
musulmans seule fois quand les juifs ont
monté à l'abri en relatant les
catholiques comme toujours de petites ya
des gens comme vous qui traîne et qui
s'aiment de la haine au lieu de faire en
sorte qu'on trouve les moyens de vivre
ensemble vous passez votre temps à
montrer du doigt musicienne mais l'enjeu
c'est dans ce pays où les gens qui ont
aimé elle redit qu' on mélange alors les
lumières c'est pas vous parce que les
lumières sont nés dans le refus de la
religion merci monsieur de la religion
oui monsieur mélo l'un de la démission
la plupart des vêtements et royan
monsieur mais vous n'y connaissez rien
en voyant revenir il appartenait à une
secte c'est pas possible de parler comme
ça alors qu'il a plus pas se mélanger la
plupart des grandes
elle en place par des hommes et des
femmes s'est arrêté de même croyant mais
ça dès les primaires ayant des traits d
un dépasse les rôles n'est pas croyant
alors que voltaire croyait en dieu il ne
croyait pas dans la religion alors
arrêtez vos
soutiens ranger l'histoire et oui vous
l'approprier alors comme elle avoue qu'à
trois notions petz consacrerait grande
moi ça m'embête à la jav est à peine
franchie dans votre manière je suis très
lent je suis très fan du toujours plus
et vous rejetez une permet de
s'entraîner c'est pas du tout donc vous
êtes une jeune avec des boutiques ou
témoin ouais je ne rejette personne mais
si vous venez ballmer jeu j'ai dit
simplement je dis simplement que
contrairement à vous moi je veux garder
la civilisation française cette nation
française c'est c'est une langue un art
de vivre ah bon un art de vivre avec
elle est due à la vente doit vivre un
art de link on doit une icône en
pâmoison la france où se mélangent
commencer vos ancêtres ils se sont
adaptés à l'art de doubler la mise en
scène joue pleinement je les lâche pas
comme les miens que l'on ne mangeait
rien à voir avec vous moi d'accord rien